what things do you crave to be reassured
about damn I think for me it's my
looks you want to be reaffirmed about
that yeah what are you trying to be
reaffirmed for like that you're pretty
enough yeah I think that I'm not not
that I think that I'm not like I think
I'm like good enough
but I've also Twitter Twitter has been
getting Twitter has been getting into my
mind like oh like her face is a six blah
blah blah but like her personality is a
10 and I'm like backhanded complim like
my personality isn't a time are sick so
what stood out to me about this clip was
that she took being called a six as an
insult 1 to 10 a six is above average
and I wanted to point out how modern
women are told they're special amazing
beautiful awesome their entire life so
we're to the point where women think
that being called above average cute is
insulting